bravo bravo le tas parce que vous n'avez
pas bougé par le single mais j'ai bougé
les yeux
normalement on doit même pas qu'il y ait
des yeux non mais moi j'ai bougé les
yeux en rythme de haut en bas de droite
tout le temps mais je vous ai pas vus
ben voilà c'est ça la force de la
révolte
les rebelles n'ont l'apli qui m'a pas vu
quoi on va vous faire une interview
mensonge rires ouais quand vous allez
mentir il faut que je m'en fou oui
pourquoi pas parce que c'est une
interview mensonge
ah bon ça va être dur pour vous non bien
on va voir je sais pas j'ai déjà menti
aussi c'est vrai que vous avez une
fortune en fait est que vous avez
beaucoup de beaucoup d'argent qui est
placé en actions sur le marché
international alors qu'est-ce qu'il faut
dire j'étais malade et nous la vérité
des gens que dira ce soir
alors en quoi vous êtes bourret bay away
on commande ferme est ce que est ce que
vous vous baladez toujours en limousine
vitres fumées ou fait allumer vos clubs
par vos assistants
ah oui ah ben ça évidemment
c'est dire à bédié et jeu quand on fait
ça aux hommes politiques n'y a pas de
problème ils comprennent tout souhaité
qu'on fait ça avec un artiste c'est plus
compliqué oui il est toujours inscrit à
l'udf c'est quoi le dr l'union l'union
des frontales des fromagers évidemment
ouais bien sûr oui c'est vrai jacques
higelin que j'avais été obligé d'arrêter
de fumer des pétards pour pouvoir vous
inscrire à l'udf jeu physique et a alors
arrêté à temps il ya deux mensonges à
faire un truc comptera deux fois arrêter
de fumer
voilà j'ai arrêté les buts oui vous dire
que non tu as paradis fumer des pétards
oui c'est ça oui j'ai arrêté que lui
dire mais quel budget ils ont fait des
films des têtes en juin +1 point voilà
sur le plan sexuel vous souhaitez
toujours sur tout ce qui bouge non non
non non ça veut dire non il faut dire du
nombre d'accidents sa dignité c'est ça
voudra dire que tu dis sur tout ce qui
bouge avec les noms qui fument des
pétards le dr
c'est ce que je vais arrêter de fumer
des pétards pour entrer à l'edf à lui
essuyé une question facile
vous n'êtes quand vous faites vous
tourner en province a beaucoup fréquenté
toujours beaucoup les boîtes échangistes
oui eh bien tu me regardes pas venu ça
parce que je fais mais l'as nancy quoi
le plan la bastille qu'est ce qui a bien
cette histoire est cet été à
saint-tropez avec la pornostar pourquoi
comme ça les gens vont croire trop
compliqué oui noms compliqués à paris
puis aller à la pornostar non oui
l'argent l'accord retrouvée morte dans
une pinède à côté de saint-tropez
comment est malin c'est vraiment ma
vraiment un monsieur bret le
manipulateur nez on l'a retrouvée morte
dans une pinède à côté de saint-tropez
pinède star du porno
ma dernière question jacques higelin
très très compliqué l'interview
mensonges devant les hommes politiques
ça passe tout seul vous avez déclaré
j'aimerais mourir comme elvis presley
c'est-à-dire intoxiqué au médicament aux
sucreries c'est vrai ça c'est dire oui
oui oui parce que dans le jeu oui oui
j'ai rêvé ça c'est quand même un truc de
deux les procès staliniens ou les
déchoir que ces procès sont les mecs qui
te pousse avec tout ça la côte et procès
de moscou il ya les finances ça c'est
pour enregistrer si j'ai glissé du 6 12
ans durée glissement oui alors le
résultat de ça c'est quoi
bah si vous arrivez parmentier 7 intègre
n'arrivais pas à monter au mât c'est un
test un peu grossier quand même presse
assez lourd passé vous guette toujours
là avant moi même j'y arrivais pas
adacore gros coup pour le reste on a
quoi je le démoniaque
là